hello everyone and welcome to a a
wonderful armageddon game from round
three between vishwanathan anna and wang
khao it's a game that is uh very very
important for the tournament standings
and it's a very enjoyable one so let's
dive straight into it uh so like i said
this is armageddon in their classical
game uh they played a very very solid
celestial code that ended in a draw
after some 30-something moves uh so
ananda doesn't feel that he will be able
to push for a win uh if he again allows
uh how to go for the for the swechnikov
it was an incredibly solid performance
with the black pieces so anand has to
choose something different so instead of
going uh or rather or
uh of allowing uh the vanguard to play
the sesnikov he repeats with e4 we have
c5 the sicilian defense knight to f3
knight to c6 but now bishop to b5 ah
danish medina uh rossolimo attack
g6 and now anand castles with bishop to
g7 c3 and e5 so this is the standard
fiance variation uh striking in the
center with the d4 c capture c captures
and now e captures on d4 uh grabbing a
pawn uh and now just bishop to f4 you
can't win back the pawn even if you
capture the knight here d captures and
the queen then defends the pawn so uh we
don't want the pawn just yet so bishop
to f4 on and continues development he
has to play for a win uh we have a6
challenging the bishop and bishop to c
for now we have d6 and now knight b to
d2 and here the position is a known one
usually knight the e7 is played no
knight to f6 is played but here how
plays h6 which is a kind of a losing
move yeah but uh of course
this is an armageddon game you don't
have all that much time to think about
it so it's very hard to pick up on why
this is such a bad move so anand uh
played the bishop to d5 which is kind of
the idea but uh he he misses one in
between move and that move is and i'm
just going to show it to you
a queen to b3 uh and
of course uh pawn to h6 is a new move so
already as of move 10 we have a
completely new game
but anand's bishop to d5 is the correct
way but first you have to prepare it
with with queen to b3 now the f7 pawn is
hanging so uh this is now with tempo and
also the b7 pawn is pressured so black
will not have this very useful bishop to
e6 at any point and now after black
defends with queen to e7 now the bishop
to d5 is a different story uh because
now again you go after knight to c4 we
want to win this uh d6 pawn and there's
not all that much black can do for
example bishop e5 we're going to play
bishop captures d captures on e5 and now
just rook 8 to c1 and it's a
really really bad position for black
it's uh very unrealistic to hope to
actually hold this uh you uh okay just
capturing here would be enough for white
to gain a
winning advantage you can't move the
bishop
you can't really do anything here you
can't move the queen uh to help out with
the defense of the c6 square because
then we just pick up the knight and then
you lose the e5 pawn so yeah and you
still have uh
to develop the knight and the castle to
just get a little bit of safety so this
is the way to go however anand plays
bishop to d5 first and this just allows
knight g to e7 because the bishop to d5
does not come with tempo
knights to c4 anand will win the d6 pawn
but house is not a problem you can have
that pawn i i i need to give a pawn back
either way so bishop captures on d6 and
now just rook to e8 we have bishop back
to g3 and now rook back to f8 you do not
want this knight to d6 at any point to
come with tempo so just rook f8 it's a
very solid move defends the f7 pawn and
hao only needs a draw to actually win
the armageddon game so h3 and now knight
captures on d5 grabbing that strong
bishop e captures on d5 and now of
course not queen captures i hope none of
you were considering this because then
just knight b6 and you win the game so
after he captures on the e5 knight to e7
going after the pawn this way knight
captures on d4 and now knight captures
on the e5 and here we've traded down
pretty much everything it's equal
material uh anand has the the two
knights and the bishop and how has the
two bishops and a knight so here we have
knight back to b3 and ponte b5 now
preparing to fianchetto the light square
bishop so it doesn't seem like anand
created any any winning chances here
with white however uh he does have a a
very firm grip on the position he plays
knight to d6 and knight on d6 is uh well
uh
definitely
an um
advantageous position for for a piece uh
knight to b6 and not knight to c5 so now
anand has a knight on the fifth rank and
a knight on the sixth rank and that's
just controlling so many squares uh here
we have rook to a7 and uh here
around this point uh
how was it very low on time he had like
a minute on the clock uh anand had over
four minutes on the clock and ananda
just cold bloodedly plays pawn to b3 and
he offers a rook
now of course uh as anand needs a win at
this uh this is a very very clever way
of trying to get winning chances because
if bishop captures real queen captures
now uh it's white who controls the dark
squares around the black king imagine if
one of the knights comes to f6 that's
that's just game over so of course how
does not want to allow this he plays
knight to d7 now controls the f6 square
and anand goes back knight c to e4 now
again putting pressure on that f6 square
but now you could capture on a1 because
the knight does cover the f6 square
still now he wants none of it he just
plays knight to f6 and now anand plays
rook the c1 and here anand is
threatening to pick up the bishop here
as the knight and the rook are attacking
it and what you should do is play
something like rook to c7 or bishop to
e6 but how played knight captures on e4
uh thinking that uh well anand just has
to capture and then i trade queens and
that's it i get an easy draw
and that's that's pretty much it however
on first place rook captures on c8 and
now there really isn't a good move here
for um for black
because if you move the queen let's say
queen to e7 we can just play rookie one
and how are you defending this
not a lot you can do if you play f5 uh
we can just play queen c2 and the
position is just disgusting to play for
black but we could even go for a force
line with some like rook captures and f8
queen captures knight captures pawn
captures and rook captures and you get
this position where anand is up
seemingly only one pawn but black's
position is completely shattered and it
would be way too easy to to play against
this so yeah this would be winning for
anand so how decides to give up the
queen instead rook a queen captures on
c8 knight captures and the rook
characters and it's not all that easy to
win this uh he has a rook and the knight
for a queen
and uh uh well anand has to be very very
precise here anand plays queen to g4
puts pressure on the rook here and the
knight so rook to e8 you have to defend
the knight this is the only move uh
bishop to f4 re-maneuvering the bishop
over to e3 and now rook a to e7 doubling
up on the e file bishop to e3 and now
rook to e6 so now how wants to play b4
he wants to play a5 create a blockade on
the queen side and he wants uh his rooks
to basically uh
defend everything and then it's not
going to be possible for white to push
for for anything so rook to d1 uh we
have pawn to b4 uh now not allowing
annan to start pushing his pawns and uh
rook to d3 we have a5 as planned uh and
now queen to d1 so this is one thing
that anand has he can play rook to the
e8 and he can
uh trade off a pair of rooks which is
which is the way to go knight to c3
attacking the queen and the a2 pawn now
just queen d2 now defending the a2 pawn
we have h5 and now rook to d8 without
this rook to d8 you would have to resort
to some g for uh maneuvers trying to
open up the position and going for uh
for a checkmating attack but this is
much much safer rook to d8 we have
bishop to f6 forcing the trade rook
captures with czech rook captures and
now queen to d7 we have rook to d8 and
now if you did not have the weak a5 pawn
uh this would be
much much easier to play however anand
just plays queen to c7 queen to c6 is
even stronger now but um you know of
course for uh for for when you have so
little time on the clock it is a move
you don't play here you attack the
bishop and once black defends the bishop
let's say bishop to e5 black threatens
checkmate here uh you're gonna play g3
and now after rook to d5 it seems like
black has everything under under control
because everything is absolutely
defended the knight defends the rook the
rogue defends the a5 pawn this defense
this this defends this so there's no
weakness here but you would have bishop
the c5 and now slowly but surely you
would uh uh
well either create some big problems for
for the black king on the back rank with
some ideas like queen here bishop to f8
or you can just uh play bishop to b6
queen to a8 and then win this pawn with
the bishop but still it's not all that
clear as the knight also would would
capture the a2 pawn so it's it's a very
tricky position now of course anand
would be winning here uh but um not
enough time to calculate this so anand
just plays queen to c7 he goes after the
a5 pawn now comes rook to d5
uh bangha defends it g4 now you have to
resort to this h captures h captures in
the now now you have to play bishop to
d4 this is the only way to continue
playing the game for example captures
captures and now yes your a5 pawn is
hanging but so is anan's g4 pawn uh
anand would still be better here but you
would have a better chances of maybe
defending this position however uh
knight captures on a2 was played and now
the position is completely winning for
ireland but it's not uh
it's not all that clear why so feel free
to pause the video here and try to find
the winning move for anand while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
beautiful double attack and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is queen to c6 that's the good stuff now
okay you're probably wondering yes you
are attacking the rook and the bishop
but we can just play rook to d1 check
and then defend the bishop what's the
big deal
that's exactly what happened rook to d1
with check king the g2 and now king g7
it seems like you've done nothing but
there's the incredible bishop to h6
check and now black is just getting
checkmated there's nothing you can do
about this king captures an h6 queen
captures on f6 and now uh whatever you
do it it's just not going to be enough
this spawn is coming to f4 you're going
to control all of these squares and of
course queen to h8 will will just be
checkmate so this is only one of the
variations that win but so our uh many
others are winning as well knights the
c3 was played but now just pawn to f4
rook to d2 check king to h3 and he was
in this position on mu 44 that van gaal
resigned the game and another victory uh
for vishwanathan anand that being his
third victory in a row first two wins
were in classical this one in armageddon
but still a third in a row uh here we
resign because there's no move for black
if you give one checking h4 now this is
the threat of checkmate and uh you can't
defend this if you play something like
king to h7 uh then we just capture on f7
king h8 and now king to g5 we're gonna
put the king here and then just
checkmate the the black king so
nothing you can do here uh
and of course um
it's just uh it's just pointless of
course you cannot play rook to d8 the
queen covers the d8 square so you you
really have no moves here
so yeah and that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh like i said another
very nice victory for anand in a row
three in a row uh this would be if you
guys are interested in the standings
after three rounds these are the
standings so anand is winning uh with
seven and a half points as you know you
get three points for a win in the
classical and only one point for a win
uh in the in the armageddon uh so here
uh and uh as you can see on and has
seven and a half so that's uh two uh two
times three for classical uh one draw
and one win in the armageddon wesley saw
in second place with six magnus with
five and a half in third place maxine uh
in fourth place with four and a half
with four points and each gear in
shakhtar and mamidyarov wang khao with
three points to paulov with two
aryantari which do end her job of
not being his tournament for the moment
with one and a half points in tenth
place
uh so yeah there you have it hope you
enjoyed the standings as well
i would like to thank valentin moreira
anand
richard knapp and raymond young for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
spectacular event
until it finishes
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day